[Music]
fans are very sad because the originals
is coming to an end are they gonna be
happy with the finale no it's the end
how can it be happy I hope they're kind
of pleased the whole premise was that it
was the last days of the mikaelsons I
hope that they are left with something
that they feel slightly fulfills that
premise but I don't know I really I
think that I think that there's going to
be there were gonna be tears Daniel
Gillies billion on the originals these
writers have maintained a level of play
no surprise entire way through so I
don't think that there's gonna be I
think that we've sufficiently prepared
our audience to be sort of gut-punched
at any given moment
yes I don't accept that did you steal
anything from set
yes what
[Music]
it still suits okay I confess leave me
you know what CW leave me alone
here's the deal they were cut
specifically for my dimensions who else
was gonna wear them who you deserve to
have I deserve them in some way as a
token as seven or eight was that last
day on set Lake I mean were you guys
emotional are you happy that this
chapters closed
I was actually trembling and in the last
scene it was a strange sensation I don't
think I've ever experienced anything
quite you know the only other time I
felt like that was when I married my
wife so maybe it was a liberating thing
[Music]